Ngày 21 thành 6 năm, nguyện chính trọng 2 mấy năm.
Trúc thịt khu chứng mấy sáng lập tở thành niệm,
Cơ quan muốn loạn của hội Việt Nam cách bạng thành niệm.
Thư giấu móc ấy, báo chi cách bạng Việt Nam chính thức ra đời,
trở thành một công cụ tuyên chuyển sắc bánh, có phận lan thoả lý tưởng cách bạng,
khơi dậy tin thần yêu nước và củ vũ mạnh mẽ cho phòng chào đấu tranh
dành được lập xan tạo dài vấn đất nước.
Trong những năm tháng khám chiến, báo chí lần 1 củ vũ tin thần Tò lớn
lòng hành công nhân dân, vượt qua sang khó, có phần làm lên tháng lợi phải phang của cách mạng.
Puy đất lức thống nhất và bước vào xây đoạn kiến thiết, lợi mới và phát triển,
báo chiếc tiếp tục phát vi vá trò, là cân thông tin chủ lực,
chuyến tại nước lối chính sách của đàn, lính cán bộ, nạm viên,
lực lượng bú trang và nhân dân, có phần tạo nên sự đông thuận trong tròa sã hội.
Bước vào thời kỳ công nghệ số, báo chi Việt Nam không ngừng lợi mới,
tính dụng công nghệ để thống tin nhân chó hiệu quả hơn.
Trong với cảnh thống tin bùng nổ,
vá trò định hướng của báo chi càng chờ nếu quán chồng,
nói hỏi các cơ quan báo chi phải sáng tạo về nội dung,
hình thức và phương phát triển tại.
Nội dung chính là trái tin của báo chi,
và nội dung quyết định sự xóm của báo chi.
Nội dung quyết định kể tính dụng quả tính tổ kịch,
báo chi, và phương tiện trở thông,
kể nền tạm,
công nghệ là chỉ là cái định truyền kể thống tin đó đi thông.
Kể kể păng gơm, kể chất lượng thông tin của báo chi.
Mới là bình đề quyết định và lôn luôn phay là cái mục tiêu,
mà những ngày là báo của chúng ta rồi đề.
Bởi vì chỉ có như thế thì báo kiết thật sự,
mới là khôi trở sả hội.
Bởi vì nó mới là chất giấm của người là báo kết nạng.
Tung quan của người dân đến được, có thể đảm của người dạ.
Báo chi của người, vậy đảm,
đến được kia sẻ là bây giờ anh mỗi thêm một sự thông tin.
Anh một sự bại đó rất là nhiều,
cái ra chỉ có lộ của báo chi,
báo chi cứ mở ra rồi là,
là đây là báo viết có.
Chất những dịch biến không nừng của thế giới thông tin,
báo chi Việt Nam đang lưới mặt với yêu cầu đổi mới quan dân
từ tư duy là báo cách thức truyền tài,
đến công a sản xuất nội dung và đạo đất nghe nhập.
Hơn bao giờ hết, mỗi nhà báo hôm nay,
cần dự bước bản lịch chính trị,
nâng cao chuyên môn và phát viên tinh thần chắc nhập với xá hội.
Báo chi, mọng trong những người cơ quan,
có thể ràng là một cái lực lượng,
tinh phòng, bây giờ họng trong các tự tưởng,
vòng qua nó chung của mưu là,
thì nhiều gồm báo bệnh là tính từ tự tụt của đánh,
và đo càn phòng bác các bạn đến xa trái,
trong thời trang tới,
và chúng tôi cũng mong rằng,
cơ quan báo chi sẽ có nhiều,
các kê chung tình,
kể khán đổi dung,
để khá hình thức,
để khá phương pháp,
để mà lăng tỏ thông tin,
nhăn thơ, mạnh hơn, kịp hà hơn.
Nhưng ta cùng nhau trung sức làng,
biết tầm sây dựng một cái
rồi ngú người làm báo,
nhẹnh bán vệ chính trị,
nhẹnh cảm về,
bình thế, số sắc về qua không ngẹn,
nhấn văn, chinh nhận,
nhấn đại,
vì nhấn rất tụt,
rất cả vì lợi của ra dân tầm.
Một chăm năm,
một thành trình không ngừng vì,
của báo chi các mạng Việt Nam,
trong bối cảnh mới,
với sương mạnh cao cả là câu nối giữa đàn,
nhàng nước với nhận dân,
cùng khách phọng phát triển không ngừng,
báo chi Việt Nam sẽ tiếp tục vực mước,
rồi mới,
và rống khóc nhiều hình lưỡa,
cho sự nghiệp chung của xanh tậu,
vì một Việt Nam,
hùng cường,
và phát triển, bình vẫn.